[Musique]
ce soir je suis chauffeur que vous avez
appelé pour amener votre ami
votre carte de crédit ne passe pas
entrer
[Musique]
vous me demandez pas s'il est bien
rentré ils ne font vos appareils photo
portable tout ce qui aura pu servir
enregistré ce que vous lui avez faire tu
as frappé à la mauvaise porte papillon
[Musique]
tu as vu star trek oui monsieur tu
penseras mottez cinq sur cinq
[Musique]
roberge pensé à toi aidez au hasard les
gens ont des problèmes comme ça c'est
très bien mais ça comblera pas le vide
que tu as dans le coeur
je me sens obligé de dire ce genre de
choses je suis ta salade me
[Musique]
mc
suzanne emma elle travaillait dans un
monde dangereux
j'ai visionné toutes les vidéos de
surveillance il se passer à autre chose
sans cette chambre qui l'a fait sam
les gens que nous cherchons en t'engager
des tueurs d'élite
ils font le ménage personne n'est à
l'abri
n'imaginez pas ce que vous avez
déclenché
mais elle est entrée en guerre contre
nous mais vous inversez les rôles c'est
vous qui est en guerre contre moi
[Musique]
je à lichtenberg
l'erreur qu'ils ont fait c'est de tuer
mon ami personne ne s'en sortira
on doit tous expier nos fautes
tiens